let the baton send bonanza begin when
Matt Reeves the co-writer and director
of the upcoming superhero film the
Batman chaired the Twitter the first
camera test of Robert Pattinson as
Gotham's greatest protector the internet
practically collapsed in on itself for a
brief moment it felt as though the world
stopped turning a sudden halt spurred by
the thousands of tweets sent out by fans
responding to the big reveal time is a
thing that crows cares for every day
what you no notice as with any reveal of
the sorts one that gives the world the
first official glimpse of an actor in
costume as a beloved internationally
recognized pop-culture figure reactions
to Pattinson as Batman have been mixed
the majority of early responses to the
reveal were positive with countless
Twitter users gushing over the first
look footage one user wrote I'm ecstatic
this movie will be amazing another added
that they enjoyed both the way the baton
sent suit looked and the score teased in
the camera test video writing the Batman
teaser looked really dope I especially
loved the tone that was playing during
it hope to get a fleshed-out version of
it when it releases plenty of fans
analyzed the video with a keener eye
picking up on possible references the
Batman's past and to other iterations of
the character comparisons were made
between the new bat suit for the Batman
and the costume seen in Batman Arkham
Knight Arkham origins and Batman Gotham
night many also noted that the video
felt somewhat like a tease for a
daredevil project since it's dimly lit
and doused in a striking red hue similar
to the colour of the Marvel heroes suit
one Twitter user wrote I'm definitely
getting some daredevil vibes the new
Batman suit looks incredible for what it
is man I'm so excited for Matt Reeves
take on the character one fan who was
actually one of several who presented
this theory posited that the new bat
symbol could be made from a gun perhaps
the one used to murder Bruce Wayne's
parents the van also wrote on Twitter
that Pattinson looks amazing and that
they can't wait to see the Batman
another fan tweeted a simple camera test
and I'm 300 times more excited for
Pattinson his batman the initial wave of
positive reactions to the Batson reveal
was soon met with a negative way
naturally some people slam the reveal
video is lame and stupid and used plenty
of unsavory words to criticize the way
Pattinson looks as Batman
one user tweeted so basically it's yet
another ugly armor suit only this time
they couldn't even be bothered to make
the M
look good Wow is there a rule at WB DC
that no Batman actor can have a
decent-looking costume anymore
these questions are vital ones another
fan wrote on Twitter the new Batman suit
is ugly if you ask me I do like the mask
in the collar but I'm not a fan of the
armor look meanwhile NRG esports Richard
King Richard Nelson didn't mince his
words writing bro that Batman reveal is
terrible this trend of unfiltered
reactions to the reveal continued all
across Twitter with one fan tweeting
excuse me for my language but that is
just awful I know Ben Affleck had
doubters but as soon as we saw him in
the suit no one no one doubted then I'm
a huge Batman fan and this may very well
be the first time I don't go see the
movie while that ban clearly believes
Ben Affleck was the best Batman and that
Pattinson can never measure up others
have said that seeing this reveal for
the Batman solidifies the notion that
Christian Bale is the best actor to have
stepped into the Batsuit one user argued
Batman should have ended when Christian
Bale stopped playing him stopped over
killing it a pleco is terrible
Robert is out here looking like
daredevil stop it All Things Considered
this feels like a fairly normal response
to a reveal of this caliber some vans
have maintained a cool head and advised
others to do the same until the Batman
actually opens in theaters as one fan
tweeted people deciding the new Batman
is chapter one short teaser image
I thought guardians of the galaxy looked
terrible after one image a talking
raccoon in a tree no thanks
yeah it's one of my favorite films wait
and see the Batman flies into theatres
on June 25th 2021 check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos about your favorite DC
characters are coming soon subscribe to
our YouTube channel and hit the bell so
you don't miss a single one
[Music]